hello everyone I am Dmitry Petrov we're
going to talk about data and machine
learning
we'll talk about thermal processes where
IML is special in terms of practices we
will talk about data ocean
reproducibility and work cloves and but
let's first introduce myself right now
I'm building a start-up in San Francisco
we basically build tool for tools for
data scientists before that I work at
Microsoft wise data scientist at
Microsoft for like almost five years and
before I work at academia I have done
some research is related with machine
jordan as well
and also I work I start to work at my
first project with part of us in 2004 I
think so I start using Python and like
from version 2.2 for many years I quit
from Python and now I started again
because like all data stake usually
based Python today and in one of my work
so reference to the previous talk in one
of my work I was a data scientist with
[Music]
own call duties and you can take a look
at my Twitter which is full stack ml so
it's reference to the last talk again so
first let's think what is what what
makes data what makes machines special
when we work with on machine learning
project we usually have a two different
kind of set of tools for your Shannon
code and versioning data reversing data
by version code by a get as I usually
write it's a good practice and but data
beliefs separate separately
and it is a very usual case when you
have like a dozens of Georgians of your
models graphs and obstetrics cetera
these files have usually no connection
with say your code and people tend to
use meaningful names for data files and
it seems to work until you really need
them whole which was built like in
previous week week or and then you try
to check out your code you see that code
is here but data files it's not clear
which one is related to your code file
or it can be opposite you have a model
you know this is a model this is a file
that I need but I don't really know what
exact code I use and give this situation
not really doesn't really help just
because you have a separate tools for
that the things we can become even worse
if you work in a team like a small
second sometimes you need to revert your
model because there is some issues in
production for example and or you need
to pass transfer some of your your job
to call it and it's again you have to
file separately data separately and it
creates a lot of out of different
destruction in your team and it's it
seems a little bit strange because we
use the best practices and we know we
know that right we use get weeks we save
we store our files and for some reason
it still doesn't work and the question
is why and to answer the question you
need to stop back
and think not about the tool you should
you should think about work law you use
and even methodology that you use and
today many companies especially a
companies large companies which work as
data for many years they realize that
data science is different from software
engineer engineering as software was
different from hardware design and
[Music]
instead of trying to document the
software engineering tools to data
science you should think like what what
is actually needed for data science what
we should change in workflow should we
change our methodologies and this is
actually not easy to do because it took
us about 20 years to build great
methodology and software and tools for
software development we moved from
waterfall process to agile in terms of
methodologies we created get distributed
version control system instead of like
huge monolithic all configuration
management systems and we invented
continuous integration continuous
delivery and etcetera etcetera a unit a
sentence a lot of good things which
supposed to help us but in some
circumstances did not really help and so
watch company realized this problem and
they in and many of big companies have
built internal which is called which is
usually called data science platforms
you probably know that like uber has his
own platform I work with one of those
platform when I worked at Microsoft
Netflix has own platform some companies
are selling a building this platform and
selling for other companies but we need
to understand what what concept they use
what is important in what is the
important data science projects and a
few artifacts first
this plot from operating by experiments
not by coat and not welcome it's
experiments means code and data and also
the process machine Jordan passes
metrics driven and usually platforms
assign metrics tour experiments so it
helps you in navigating and in
communication in the team and some of
the platform support more advanced
scenarios like reproducibility
reproducibility actually taught advance
that's must have I would say for any
platform and machine doing pipelines and
the process itself is different as well
so component to software engineering the
process the process we have a try often
he roars right we can try like different
ten different ideas and only one of
those will work at very based also first
of all I am talking about kind of more
mature ml project right when you're
starting the project from stage you
probably don't have such kind of problem
and so and we see these good practices
from in watch companies and we decided
to make these practices available for
everyone so we built an open-source
project
it's basically open source data science
platform we call the data ocean control
yet Dec dot dot o-r-g
we are trying to build a platform data
science platform on top of open open
source stack we took it as a foundation
for this technology and we basically
extend it by additional commands by data
files by metrics by pipelines and
reproducibility and other typical for
this sense platform things
so yeah
we use a concept of experiments as a
committin branch but it contains code
plus data we manage data separately from
code which means you have a separate
remote for code like for example github
and separate remote for data it might be
s3 it might be like Google Cloud might
be just a separate machine with SSH
access for example we so this to us is
optimized for large data files which
means in a gig gigabyte range from 101
to 100 GB and yeah it supports metrics
pipelines and it covers reproducibility
so you can define commands and the tool
I can help you really produces command
or I can define come on to my machine
transfer your repository and you will be
able to reproduce the machine or instead
of reproducing you can sync my data
through some data remote so let's talk
about data files first if you you
probably heard about git LFS this is a
way how you can work with data files
with git
so there is a tool which supports watch
data files but usually people try to try
get elephants in machine learning
projects and some and usually they quit
from get lafete just because it does not
support large data files as you data
scientist named so there is limitation
only files has to be less than 2
gigabytes if you have more than 2 3
files it creates some
additional performance issue and what is
important in a usual data science prob
is a garbage collector for data files
because when you iterate on experiments
100 times you create 100 100
intermediate data sets you create 100
models and probably 300 different kind
of plots most likely you'd you stack
with visa space issue in your local
machine or you probably don't even need
as much experiments on your cloud and
and it supports like pure cloud so you
have to you have to work with only like
a limited amount of services for get
alpha specifically so with our approach
you just install a tool and then in any
get depository you have addition you can
you can add data files like in this
example you just say DBC and and some
binary file and now you have a file in
your repository but what does it mean to
have a file in your repository because
we don't push data to we don't want to
push data to get direct write or even
inject instead we are pushing meta files
so you can see like it's status command
it's it show that and image dot the dot
DBC file was created to do this is a
file meta file and it modifies get
ignore it ignore we need this
modification just because we don't want
to track and actually the actual file
image dot zip file so the tool does
everything for you and you just need to
commit these changes and this
information will be available for any in
your repository repository so you can
you can push the repository your
colleagues can I can see data set or not
dataset the repository and she will see
that a data file was created it does not
necessarily mean that she will see the
data file it's separate story but at
least she will see the fact that the
file was connected and yeah the changes
have to be committed of course to sync
data you need to create a remote and
this is a similar concept to the kinds
of of gitche modes
you just create a remote specify a
protocol like like here like s3 and then
your bucket and then just simply push
your data after data is uploaded your
colleague can download data the same way
as you push the data so she should use
GBC pool with the same repository and
get the same data set this is how you
can create you can train a model your
machine and transfer the smart to you to
your colleague another important
equation is optimization of this product
of this part of this process when you
work on a scale of thousands of
gigabytes probably each of your checkout
is going to take a while right so if you
need to copy like 20 gigabytes of data
even though in the in a good with a good
hard way it will take probably a minute
or even more and you probably don't want
to wait for I mean it for each check out
so the tool optimize this process
it based on hard links and tools never
copy data again owns file was created no
matter how it's done
so it will never create a copy
everything based on on habían hard looks
the few more optimization techniques
like RF links for some modern file
system also we compute checksum most
affordable disability and checksum again
we do not attempt you checksum twice
because it's it's still it's again quite
heavy operation so as a result of this
optimization even if you do check out
with a few hundreds of gigabytes it
takes you just a second to do the check
out because there are no copy of no data
copies so let's talk briefly about
pipelines pipeline is kind of important
concept what it does mean that you need
like a pipeline of in a separate step
you can help just a pipeline in one
command like your jupiter notebook for
example which takes some input and
provide some output or you may have a
more complicated by plan when you take
data they take raw data do some
transformation then do fish extractions
and model and then evaluation of the
model and the tool gives you ability to
define the pipeline there is a command
when you can specify input and output
and so the command you'd like to run and
this is a way how you can create a
dependency graph right that it works
the tool runs command and again it
modifies metafiles so everything on the
tool based on the meta files and all the
meta files goes to your repository this
is a way how you collaborate and
communicate with with colleagues so in
this in this simple example one file was
created like images which is a directory
as a result of under high means the file
so and reproducibility it it doesn't
matter how much how many step you have
in your pipeline it doesn't matter how
complicated your pipeline it might be
just a straight line it might be some
hierarchy we have a way to reproduce
your your pipeline and especially
important when you work with multiple
stages because it the tool can track
dependency what was changed what has to
be revealed what we can ignore
rebuilding and it helps to iterate
faster on your experiments so and I
think it's workflow overflew this is
very usual workflow in software engineer
it called it called this called
[Music]
get flow right when you have just a one
master or some a branch and you create a
feature branch and then merge it back
sometimes you may have a few kind of
master branch like a master or
production development etc etc but in
software engineering it work in the same
way you just create feature you develop
future and you merge feature and usually
in soft when Janine if you don't fail
actually it's a bit
complicated question you can fail in
terms of in terms of quality of work you
can fail in term of time you spend if
spent but usually still feature will
deliver it and data sign in data science
the practice a little bit different
because you can come up with a few ideas
and only one of those might work or only
one of those it will produce you the
best result and this is an example of
three idea that you come up with in two
of those idea you might like additional
steps and only one of those one of the
idea was merged into a master branch and
why do we need it sounds like a
complicated workflow right compelling to
you to a user of software development
workflow but it first it reflects the
nature of data science Bell and the
second this is a way how you can scale
your work in a team one guy can work in
the first idea the second guy can work
in the second idea and the third
understood and get a foundation can help
you collaborate all by all of those
result results and a few tricks which
aim that important in data science
workflow and one of those usually you
need to jump back to your previous idea
to your previous experiments and when
you jump back you usually need to create
a new branch so don't do just get
checkout something usually you need to
do get check out some something create
branch right away because you are going
to be working on starting some work from
this place and in data science sometimes
it's important to keep track of your
failed experiments it can be important
for several reasons for example
you come up with some idea you'll try
that you didn't work and you think all
right it didn't work because I did
something wrong let's keep it and later
I can I can continue this work or I can
transfer this to some some of my
colleagues and sometimes it's important
to keep failed experiment because I'd
like to show to everybody
I have tried that please don't spend
time on this idea it didn't work so and
it's important to keep this branch is
not only on your machine not only on
your local machine but pull them to a
central repository they do use and yeah
and sometimes you don't mean the sound
of experiment just clean them up and
don't spend resources on this so what is
[Music]
yeah
the couple most scenario how this tool
this kind of tool can can be used one of
those scenario is just a replacement of
git LFS when you when you need a file
back and on s3 or on your some other
servers some company use the tool to to
kind of a protocol for communication
between data scientists and engineers
who who is responsible for deployment
because they need a consistency for data
for roll backs and etc and the new
feature that we recently introduced is
experimentation on the GTF as an apache
spark so which basically means all the
things that we discuss you can use on
HDFS cluster so which means no local
much local machine is used on the foe
track and meta information but not data
so data lives on on the question it's
very important on for people who work
usually in a watch company with a large
data set they spent a lot of time for
data preparation and it's very important
to
experiment in such kind of environment
and so the question is when do you need
such kind of platforms some people don't
use any platform they happy with their
irregular tools and based on our
experience you need a tool you need a
data science platform or some similar
tool when you work in a team it helps
you on collaborating between
collaborating in your team because
otherwise you have to create you have to
reinvent basically some basic principles
you have to create ad hoc scripts and a
platform basically and platform unifies
this process plateau helps when you work
on a project for a long period of time
for example you have a project let's say
which runs for more than one year right
so this is basically your communication
with yourself in the future right you
creating a better infrastructure better
better tools for yourself in one month
and one in half a year and one year and
so we believe it's very important to
have open source data science platforms
because it will help to work on more
complicated open source machine learning
projects today the Machine open source
machine journal projects and usually
they are not kind of a long grained
project it's like someone do something
published on github and pretty much it
and we need a project we need a project
with huge community with a good
community with evolving data set with
the world in models and this sense part
for in some way how to support
these projects so thank you
please visit the tool website TV see the
torque there is a discussion forum
pretty active issue tracker in in the
github page and don't hesitate to start
the repository it's an easy way to
contribute to the project there is a lot
of activity in the last month in the
repository a lot of people company start
to start using the tool and yeah please
take a look and now I'm ready for your
questions thank you
[Applause]
yeah thanks well as introduction there's
a question right away hey thanks for the
interesting talk I was also recently
visiting your website and from the
project quite interesting what I already
wonder what is the unique unification
criteria here because there are projects
like world which more like focus on data
deep-blue duplication and data
versioning or as a model called no
public what should should one use so
what of course you are working for the
VC but what is your view toward what is
the unit you need criteria of what you
makes the best solution so DC and
there's quilt and just in a scientific
space yes yes right so so what we are
doing it's a distance platform and our
focus is supporting a workflow and not
just your sink files and for example if
you're talking about quilt it's it's a
data ocean solution right you have a
library which when you can you can use
the library to pull data to pull data to
update your data set and this is the
basics you use to use keys right
our focus is workflow and data and the
divergent is a part of the workflow this
is the first this is regarding the quilt
if you're talking about general our
focus is hand on data scientists we
don't want a good solution which ends on
like up like some of the solution hands
on just a few gigabyte data set and they
said this is unlike what they designed
just need because they use notebooks and
simple so now you see we are targeting
pretty advanced scenarios with dozens of
gigabytes with a few steps in Experion
an experiment and we do not build a
Python library
it's many other solutions so our tool is
common line tool which can be used with
any pretty much any language like Python
our spark whatever and all the wall from
zero
thank you for the wonderful talk um one
thing that happens in the real world
with data is that sometimes the shape of
your data changes over time you might
get additional fields in in a JSON
payload that sort of thing and it makes
it difficult or if not impossible to
roll back to a different version of a
model that does not have any notion of
the shape of future data is there
anything in the tool that allows you to
set like a flag or something saying at
this point forward our data now has you
know fits this schema versus the old
schema so do not roll back past this
point
yeah actually so we don't care about
schemas what we do care is file version
and file checksums what does mean if one
of your data file was updated the tool
will know that this is what what what
happened and the next disability step
will probably have some issues most
likely right if you change data set
without modifying code so we do not care
about schemas it has to be resolved on a
higher level and kind of an application
level right it's highly depends on your
the main problem and etcetera etcetera
more questions
hi I'm a bit worried about merge
conflicts do you ever run into any of
these so there's all these branches
being created by different people but if
I use the same file name as someone else
and overwrite their data what happens
yeah it's an interesting question so
much as I said we create metafiles right
and most of the job is done by made meta
files and when you do much you mostly
you need to resolve issues with
metafiles much
it's not about data files we do not
merge data files and don't even try to
do this so yeah you just solve the
conflict on on the data file level and
is there anything also upcoming or do
you consider something like
deduplication or data lineage something
like adding a code structure or
something like that because I know from
very mature data science projects which
like have terabyte or even petabytes of
data in order to do something like back
testing and so I think even with your
framework if there's a training set
which is only a few gigabytes rolling
back and forth between data and or like
this case where you have duplicated
datasets multiple reports as a company
you want to have this kind of lineage
right at you that you D duplicate and
see what went where and where does it
come from is there something do you
consider adding some feature like that I
mean a little bit leads into this what
also project provides right but in your
long run I think data science would also
benefit from that a lot if you're
talking about duplication of data data
right or rope of data then no it is
something which has to be defined on our
application level right it depends on
problem
yeah yeah so yeah I got the question so
the several scenarios first is for
example databases when you usually
usually when you build a model you need
kind of Sam Gershwin from the database
right we need to run some Queen and
based on this query you doing your
analytics or machine learning right so
this is kind of a separation line
between online system and between a
modern system and when you run query you
take data then you start your analytic
analytical machine Janet Trotter a
project when you need to upload data it
has to happen again but our system does
not care about this thing right if you
integrate the system into some your
online system it did so it is going to
depend of different scenario yeah but
the system does not interact with some
line and this actually this design
decision so we need to separate system
from data engineer from data engineers
from system for machine learning people
from analytics because requirement are
sort of different all right so before we
thank Dimitri again I would like to
remind you of your karma once again and
please take the stuff with you that you
brought and then we will reconvene after
the coffee break
thanks Dima for the nice talk
[Applause]